the governor of arizona a republican
makes it official signing off on
election results declaring democrat joe
biden
the winner in his state by just over 10
thousand votes
arizona's secretary of state assured
voters the election was conducted
by the book transparency accuracy and
fairness
in accordance with arizona's laws and
elections procedures
despite numerous unfounded claims to the
contrary
those claims coming from none other than
president donald trump
and his personal attorney rudy giuliani
who met with some arizona state
republicans
still looking for evidence of fraud that
is yet to materialize
while the president's supporters
gathered outside
four out of five legal challenges waged
by republicans in arizona
have been dismissed by the courts in
wisconsin the president's campaign paid
3 million dollars for recounts in two
counties
but that only turned up more votes for
biden and that state too
has now officially been certified for
the democrat
a recount is essentially an audit of the
process that verifies the accuracy
of the balloting process that takes
place on election day
i promise that this would be a
transparent and fair process and it was
both wisconsin and arizona were won by
trump
in 2016. this makes joe biden the first
democrat to win a presidential election
in arizona since
1996. president trump has
five days to contest the results there
and in wisconsin which he is expected to
do
kristen salumi al jazeera wilmington
delaware